ashley is going to start off this hour
in California hi Ashley how are you hi
Dave I'm so glad to be talking to you
you too what's up I've been married for
six years and I'm certainly by not
pregnant
waiting for my third child I'm taking
care of my kids at home and I'm feeling
financially insecure especially if
something happens to my marriage like in
the future so two things that I did so
far recently I learned that my husband
can contribute to an IRA for me so I had
I had one open for myself and I had him
you know combine our the second thing I
was I had and combined all of our
accounts to one joint account and I just
want to know what can I do now to start
doing financially secure or what can you
do to help me feel secure financially
secure okay so you have this latent fear
he's going to leave and take all the
money I don't I don't know I just want
to feel like being at home that I can
that I know he and I are on the same
page that I'm doing but I you know I
don't know what to like say to him and I
think he's doing everything but oh
you're not you're not discussing money
you're not on the same page you're not
making decisions together I mean we are
but I did talk to him about he did
combine all of our accounts yeah but I
mean if you're making your decisions
together then why don't you feel like
you have a voice because I feel like he
like I wanted him to combine his IRA and
his investment and with mine but you
know because he just recently you can't
you can't there's no such there's no
such thing as a there's no such thing as
a his-and-her IRA you have an IRA he has
an IRA oh by the way California law says
if you get divorced and he has a million
dollars in a 401k you get half of it
even if your name is not on it
what else can I
because I don't have any idea like what
else can I do
I can't bring in an income because I'm
staying home with these young kids I
feel like my hands are kind of tied so
he's having trouble if you're at home
with the babies and that's your choice
and that's what you want to do which is
a wonderful thing I do not know that
you're vulnerable this is an irrational
fear yeah okay I mean if it was a
rational fear there would be some things
we could do tactically to quote/unquote
protect you okay now from a relational
standpoint the two of you need to come
but you need to agree we do not make
major financial decisions without us
being in agreement
Sharon and I have that contract I don't
go buy a car and go look what I did we
do make that decision together oh I
don't go buy a piece of property and go
look what I did
we don't make a major contribution to
charity and say look what I did now I
mean she might give somebody five
hundred bucks or something but I mean
she doesn't give people five thousand
dollars I don't go buy and expensive you
know eight thousand dollar gun that she
doesn't know I'm doing and she doesn't
go buy an eight thousand dollar purse
that I don't know she's doing right so
we have an agreement that we don't spend
or make big decisions without the other
one we had secondly we have an agreement
that says that all of our monthly budget
we both have a vote on and we both agree
all the money comes in she has not made
a dime virtually a dime of income in 33
years but yet our income is described as
our income because we are married it is
ours by the way the law says it's ours
but more importantly the Spirit says
it's ours and we together are managing
our money she has as much say in what
happens with the money as I do because
that's how she and I choose to run our
relationship and by the way it's the
healthiest methodology for your marriage
and has the highest probability of being
successful financially when you learn to
work too
together like that in unity trusting
each other having experience so a budget
where every dollar has a name we both
have a vote those dollars are all
assigned that you have equal say in the
money even though you technically did
not bring it into the household number
two number one is you make a pinky swear
and spit shake we don't make major
decisions without each other
number three understand that the law
gives you access to any assets that have
his name on them in the event of a
divorce or a death number three put
together a will that takes care of you
guys if something happens to him number
four put together life insurance that
takes care of you guys if something
happens to him lots of it lots of life
insurance it's not that expensive and so
those kinds of things can tactically
make you secure but if somehow you've
been delivered a message by your parents
or society are some stupid but college
professor that says you don't add value
to your family because you're at home
with the kids then that's something
that's screwed up in your head that you
have to fix is that right I agree with
you okay listen thank you Billy Graham
had a momma right well he changed the
world that's an important job you have
maybe the most important job on the
planet now if you if you want to do a
career while you're doing that I'm not
mad at you for that but don't listen to
voices that devalue your position okay
okay thank you thank you for that list
tactically you go do those things but
listen if you emotionally decide to be
insecure none of those things are gonna
fix you I agree
okay absolutely hey thanks for the call
kiddo well I got to tell you man my wife
get her hillbilly up somebody to values
mom cuz she's been a full-time mom for
33 years now now she's full-time me me
running around you know bothering six
grandkids on a regular basis so and by
the way I have three absolutely
incredible stellar adult children
they're absolutely incredible
stellar husbands and wives and
absolutely incredible stellar mommies
and daddies themselves with incredible
walks with Jesus and incredible careers
and you can blame it on one thing if you
want Sharon Ramsey so I don't know how
you can create more value in society
than that